Merkel Lord of Bones is one of the best
commanders to come out of 2022 this s
Mana Aban Commander has indestructible
if you have less than or equal to your
starting life total and whenever a
non-token creature you control dies you
may Exile it if you do create a token
that's a copy of it except it is an
enchantment and loses all other card
types so what's the game plan ramp sack
protect and win we're going to ramp into
our commander and using sacrifice
Outlets we're going to turn creatures
with powerful static abilities into
enchantments and drain our opponents out
of the game we've also got a couple of
combos which we'll go over
[Music]
later first up there's ramping we're
running the classic Suite of Mana dos L
War elves find horn elves Elish Mystic
aon's Pilgrim birds of paradise and even
elves of deep sh Shadow all of which tap
for a single Mana of the colors in our
deck in addition we have sanctum Weaver
that can generate a ton of Mana thanks
to everything turning into an
enchantment an important thing to
remember is that an enchantment doesn't
get Summoning Sickness so if we manage
to turn one of these Mana creatures into
an enchantment thanks to Merkel we can
use their Mana abilities straight away
and of course the most important Mana
talk we have is devoted Droid for Just
Two Mana we get a zero two that can tap
for a green and then at any time we can
put a minus one minus1 counter on it to
untap it with Merk and play we can then
look to generate Infinite Green Mana we
can simply use devoted druid's untap
ability straight away to put itself into
the graveyard and turn it into an
enchantment as I mentioned enchantments
don't get summoning sickness nor do they
get affected by minus one-1
counters now that we've r into our
commander it's time to start putting
things into the graveyard there are a
number of ways that you can do this you
can use creatures with free sacrifice
Outlets such as carry and feeder Feria
and W Rider artifacts such as ashnod's
alter fian alter you can even use skull
clamp to generate some card advantage
while you're at it we're also running
the budget friendly survival of the
fittest evolutionary leap with all of
these creatures going to the graveyard
we're taking full advantage of zulaport
cutthroat blood artist and cruel
celebran these creatures will help us
stay alive while draining our opponents
out of the
[Music]
game and with all of these enchantments
entering the battlefield utilizing the
constellation mechanic was a no-brainer
constellation is a triggered ability
that triggers when an enchantment enters
the battlefield the core ones we're
running are Stan's champion and Idol of
blossoms for card draw doomwake giant
for board wipes and nessian Wanderer to
hit lands and while they don't
specifically have constellation they
effectively have the same ability both
ajani's Chosen and Aron of Sun's Grace
generate creatures when enchantments
come into play which is just more fodder
for blood artist and friends there are
more constellation cards you can use but
I'll leave that up to you to explore
those options
[Music]
now here's the part of the deck that is
the most customizable the utility
creatures again we're looking for
creatures with powerful static abilities
to take advantage of here are some of
the key ones that I'll be playing we've
got averson Angel of Hope to make
everything indestructible Fountain watch
to give your enchantment shroud a m
sensor to restrict your opponents for
being able to search for answers drth
magistrate to stop commanders from being
cast and other annoying spells g a
glorious resurrector to take opponent's
creatures and turn them into
enchantments there's also wandering
archaic to attacks and potentially copy
our opponent's spells there are a whole
heap of others that you can use use the
ones that best suit your play group meta
to support all of these token
enchantments we've got added bonuses
from anointed procession Second Harvest
sphere of safety Sterling Grove and
Starfield of Nicks do not sleep on these
cards
to round out the deck we have a handful
of removal spells and board wipes again
chop and change these out to suit your
groups
meta as for combos we're focusing on
turning devoted Druid into an
enchantment once we've done that we have
unlimited power the most basic way to
win is simply cast a massive torment of
Hellfire or exanguination
otherwise you can simply dump all of
your Mana into Destiny spinner and turn
all of your lands into creatures if
you've got the money crater ho Behemoth
and finale of Devastation can also
assist Destiny spinner with the win you
could also think about adding walking
ballista to the deck for the same reason
and since we're running blood artist and
friends you can also combine animate
dead and leonan Relic water for infinite
PS
[Music]
and finally how do we beat this deck
well there are two ways exiling
graveyards and stopping cards from going
there path to Exile and rest in peace
are two good examples of this and then
there's also enchantment board wipes
like cleansing Nova dismantling wave and
all is dust just watch out for those
blood artist triggers though and that
about does it for this Deck Tech I hoped
you liked the video be sure to leave a
like if it helped you out there is a
link to the full deck list in the
description down below what commanders
would you like to see next be sure to
leave a comment and let me know and uh
that's about it have a good night guys
and I'll see you next time